[Musik]
Berlin Hauptstadt der Spione wie
effektiv ist der deutsche Geheimdienst
gerade in Krisenzeiten vor der
russischen Botschaft treffe ich mich mit
dem Experten Erich schmidt-boom denn ich
will Spion werden das Gute ist ja ich
fange nicht bei Null an ich habe
tatsächlich schon mal als Geheimagent
gearbeitet in den frühen 80er Jahren ich
habe meinen Ausweis hier dabei können
sie mal sehen
ja aber auch wenn sie noch so fröhlich
und interessiert gucken dass es eher ein
Zeichen von Auffälligkeit und als ergänz
sollen sie auf völlig unauffällig durch
die Gegend schleichen Deutschland hat ja
15 Jahre lang die Gegenspionage
eingestellt würden Sie sagen Deutschland
war da naiv oder sehr sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr naiv
ausgesprochen naiv aber das resultiert
daher dass der Bundesnachrichtendienst
immer wusste bei der Gegenspionage bei
diesem katzenspiel haben die Russen
größere Erfahrung und die größeren
Erfolge ach so dann haben wir einfach
aufgegeben gesagt okay dann dann machen
wir es gar nicht also Doppelagent zu
führen hohes Risiko wenn man nie weiß
auf welcher Seite der wirklich steht und
in den allermeisten Fällen standen
doppellagenten auf der östlichen Seite
hier ist ja die russische Botschaft
direkt gegenüber ist das
Abgeordnetenhaus haben sie da Ideen wie
man die Virus vorspielen also sichern
kann also es gibt diese Technik dass man
mit leserstrahlen die man auf
Fensterscheiben richtet innen drin das
gesprochene Wort mithören kann oder auch
die Abstrahlung hinter Tastaturen aber
das Spionage habt ihr ganz einfach sie
stellen einen Radio auf die Fensterbank
und schon scheiterte Lauschangriff an
den Klängen eines Wiener Walzers
und und gibt es da Unterschiede dass man
sagt wenn jetzt Helene Fischer läuft
schreckt es noch mehr ab und es ist
effektiver oder das ist ein
hauptproletarischer aber dieselbe
Wirkung
ich möchte mein angewandtes Agenten
Wissen gerne an ein potenzielles
Spionageopfer weitergeben hallo Lutz von
der heute schon gegen Spionage er hat
Grundel vom Bündnis 90 die Grünen bevor
es losgeht eine Sache ich müsste kurz
checken ob sie nicht verwandt sind
in seinem Büro sitzt der dem Russen
direkt gegenüber sind sie denn auch
wichtig also dass man sagt da gibt es
auch durchaus was was man ausspionieren
kann jeder abgeordnetes sage ich jetzt
ohne Witz muss natürlich schon darauf
achten ob hier leichtfertig was
preisgeben wird das muss man tun nichts
vermeiden
[Musik]
fühlt man sich denn manchmal unwohl dann
auch also jetzt mal ehrlich wenn ich
meine das man muss halt bestimmte
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen ergreifen wenn ich
hier alleine sitze dann denke ich
gewöhnlich nicht laut Herr Grundel
scheint sich der Gefahr überhaupt nicht
bewusst zu sein ich will helfen mit dem
Tip top-radio Abwehr Trick wo werden wir
jetzt absolut safe ja wir müssen also
schreien und dann würde ich mich jetzt
abwenden müssen von Ihnen weil sonst
sehen wir ja Lippenbewegung und wenn ich
wenn ich den entgegenwirken würde und
mit ihnen niederbayerisch reden würde
dass die mich nicht verstehen verstehen
sie ja nichts das ist genial
wenn sich jemand mit Spionage auskennt
dann die CIA was hält ein Topspion vom
deutschen Geheimdienst der BND
particular
get and system money
okay das mit der wenigen Kohle klingt
gar nicht gut dann frage ich doch mal
bei den Russen nach Rui menias Luigi
yarachu
na gut die Antworten jetzt auch nicht
durch die Scheibe ne
wenn sie bisschen
hallo Youtube unten könnt ihr den Kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
Infobox neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante Videos Verlinkungen Komma
vielen Dank
[Musik]